c'est non l'ire des proches dans votre
cabinet pas et demi en plus des
calembours des jeux de mots c'est pas
vous en fait beaucoup mais il y en a par
exemple particulièrement remarquable
vous expliquez vous en prie le mode
académie française
oui ah oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ça ah
oui c'est vrai oui j'aime pas les
calembours
quand on utilise un expert peut pas
faire autrement c'est pour des raisons
purement historique nous donner oui
parce qu'il existait au quai conti
il ya actuellement sept au magnifique
avec ses de ces deux cd commun qui ont
tous tout le monde c'était là qu'on
fabriquer du pain et ont fabriqué à
l'époque
enfin autant de lou 13 jan fabriquer le
pain différemment d'aujourd'hui savent
fabriquer la croûte dans un des deux
petits bâtiments il a mis dans l'autre
et puis après tout la victoire on réunit
c'est exactement
voilà et quand on voulait les étrangers
qui viennent à paris chercher le pain
parisien de ce côté de la scène qui
était très très coté c'est le meilleur
pain de france les gens demandaient où
est le pain et les on répondait c'est là
qui a des croûtes et c'est l'académie
et c'est là à dire d'académie et c'est
l'académie française c'est là qu'elle
est française monsieur oui et c'est
comme ça que voilà et alors comme ces
lieux ont été occupées par richelieu par
la suite à ces données c'est l'académie
il faut à pierre desproges vivent
heureux en attendant la mort mais je
trouve que vous n'avez pas de bonne
humeur sur la sur la couverture
bien sûr toutes vos photos je trouve
votre livre très drôle mais mira vous
n'êtes pas drôle du tout bas fait du
moins ne souriez pas vous êtes là
sérieux s'il se passe avoue donc ça vous
en voulez à quelqu'un non là je suis du
bit est ce que vous êtes constipé
monsieur de passe cette photo je suis
dubitatif
cette du bit est dubitatif ne pas
confondre avec les accusateurs précoce
je le dis pauvre
bon alors vous avez vous avez de solides
when we solide wen alors où il ya bon je
vais lire le petit passage là parce que
la voulait résumer les coiffeurs sont
l'élément le plus totalement inutiles
d'une nation avec les militaires les
académiciens julio iglesias et des
crottes sur les trottoirs alors pourquoi
parce que j'ai horreur qu'on ne rit pas
de la tête par derrière en racontant des
conneries dans le dos
c'est vrai les messieurs si vous leur en
voulais parce qu'il possède la langue
comme si elle était morte alors que
c'est quelque chose de vivant
la preuve ici les traités de parasites
de la société de vieux croûtons vieilles
tiges creuses guignols vert pomme un gay
chapeau à plumes à la con une épée de
paniers sur une faute d'impression
ce sont des querelles des ddn stérile je
suis pas quelqu'un de haineux simplon
j'aime bien le mot mossi
et puis quand je pars sur une idée par
une plaine du coiffeur de l'académicien
je pousse à bout c'est une caricature un
peu avec mes faibles moyens comme ceux
les caricatures de mon choix ne le fait
soit avec des prêts avec des mots voilà
pourquoi les crottes de chien parce que
parce que merde on apprend que les
ellipses et julio iglesias bon alors le
nom la loggia c'est quelqu'un sans
piston l'avons bien compris c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
ah bon c'est dommage qu'ils chantent
c'est tout il m'a demandé
et puis les taxis ou une belle
définition six ans que j'entends
beaucoup le tapis alors mille et une
raisons c'est pas les taxis serait du
racisme de mettre sur les textiles et
vous les mettez tous
aa je vais les taxis il n'y a que deux
sortes de chauffeurs de taxi 1 ce qui
pue le tabac est ce qui vous empêche de
fumée n'a pas dansé n'a pas oui le bal
c'est vrai que la vie y est c'est une
vie carcérale la vie dans un taxi et on
en ferme et on est sous un despote à
roulettes qui vous oblige
où êtes-vous à supporter son tabac ou
aux fumélois ne pas fumer ou qui nous
laisse attraper froid ou qui ferme les
fenêtres on crève de chaud aux fesses et
s'attend souvent pas tout ça vous êtes
associé de taxi elle écoute je vous
adore lui par alors vous ne mettez pas à
côté je vais vous dire c'est que si vous
cherchez un taxi partir de demain à 20
heures
quand il pleut je peux vous dire que
vous avez du mal à en trouver en quoi je
renie ce livre semblait bon et puis
évidemment vous en voulez beaucoup à la
mort mais un peu comme tout le monde oui
ben je crois qu'ils les imbéciles et les
animaux qui n'ont pas peur de mourir ou
les gens qui sont malheureux je suis pas
moi j'aime bien la vie c'est pour ça que
j'ai peur de la mort est ce que ce n'est
pas un livre drôle bien sûr mais au fond
assez philosophique gilbert si certaines
paraissent désespéré
quel est votre avis là-dessus l'humour a
toujours été la politesse du désespoir
web ont passé c'est mieux comme ça me
rappelait compte chaque fois que je le
lisais parce que je les aime bien
c'est un mot de ce culte nerfs qui n'est
peut-être pas là dedans qui dit et la
mort ne dure qu'une seconde
la première je crois ce qu'il dit c'est
dans votre centre de belhadj lots
thérapie ça n'en fait pas partie il y à
quelques histoires je ne sais pas si
vous les avez inventé ou si elles sont
vraies ou l'histoire est sûre et de
chats oui et je n'ai jamais pu vérifier
peut-être que monsieur la propre elle a
vérifié c'est une histoire qui est très
belles joues c'était ça s'est passé un
soir deux au carnegie hall de new york
pour être charte avait donné un concert
il y avait une journaliste débutante qui
est là à la fin du concert est allé voir
ray charles et qu'il était bouleversé
parce qu'on l'adoré richardson lieu dit
lahbib mettre enfin le lui a dit vous
êtes extraordinaire jugement faites vous
pour pour pour exhaler tant de bonheur
malgré cette nuit dans laquelle vous
êtes depuis toujours puisque ça va mais
sans comment faites-vous pour dégager
autant d'autant de joie de vivre malgré
votre cécité totale et richard a répondu
oh vous savez les jeunes femmes il ya
plus malheureux que moi j'aurais pu être
[ __ ] oui c'est le mot de pardon oui je
vais en prison
oui c'est moche ce mot sur un aveugle me
fait penser à la définition de l'humour
par mears un aveugle dans une chambre
noire qui cherche son chapeau noir qui
ne s'y trompe pas une édition qui
rappelait d'ailleurs qui touche à celle
de lichtenberg un gros tournant là on
sent le nom dont dont ils manquent le
manche
ouais enfin et puis les autres enfin non
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que la ville
de dans le fait de se cacher derrière le
rire on rit fort pour pour exorciser des
angoisses des craintes quand je pense à
mes personnages je vous avais des
angoisses boulot mon dieu mon four
monsieur pivot avant c'est vrai mais
j'ai toujours peur de mourir sous les
bombes
j'ai toujours peur que les enfants
soient enlevées j'ai toujours peur que
ma femme est mal quelque part j'ai
toujours peur d'être en retard à
apostrophes c'est épouvantable matin ce
sera alors le rif
je ris est-ce qu'on peut rire de tout si
le chat doit rire de vous dire s'il faut
rire de tout oui ça j'ai repris cette
histoire de rire de tout je fais une
émission à france inter
mais claude villers qui s'appelait le
grand délire et on avait des invités
curieux quelquefois et un jour on a eu
jean marie le pen comme invité on devait
avoir andrieu et jambes pour moi c'est
le même d'ailleurs nourri je ne sais
plus lequel des deux enfin un facile de
droite ou de gauche c'est lui et j'avais
dix-huit une réflexion un peu sotte avec
billère je l'avais dit si ce monsieur
vient dans l'émission moi j'ai plus
envie de rire pas envie de rire avec lui
et puis finalement je me suis repris un
peu que je réfléchi et j'ai fait parce
qu'ils sont appelés un réquisitoire
c'étaient des choses rigolotes qui vont
à la fin d'émission sur le thème peut-on
peut-on rire de tout et peut-on rire
avec tout le monde alors je répondais
oui la porte c'était le pen et je
répondais oui on peut rire absolument de
tout mais pas avec tout le monde ah ben
voilà c'est la seule restriction
il ya des gens qui jeudi en asie en
uniforme un officier ss j'ai pas envie
de me taper sur le la bedaine pour rire
voilà le et quand vous voyez la
publicité d'un film le film qui a coûté
plus cher que le débarquement sam
querrey oui bien sûr oui mais moi je
peux même rire de jean moulin si je suis
en forme mais vous en parlez valeurs
ayant bien joué
non mais c'est vrai qu'au regard de
touriste avait il ya un exemple qui
prouve qu'il est un exemple vécu c'est
une petite dépêche de la fp que j'avais
découpé quand j'étais journaliste à leur
or quand j'étais de droite il ya une
dizaine d'années et cette semaine
chaque semaine 7 degrés est
cette dépêche raconter l'histoire je
vais développer en dix lignes je
trouvais que c'était très très
significatif
dans une petite ville du sud des états
unis les membres du ku klux klan avaient
défilé dans la rue en plein jour et les
enfants des écoles en les voyant avec
leurs tuyaux sur la tête et est mort de
rire et légendes du club clame été
obligé de changer d'uniforme parce que
ça faisait rire les petits enfants quand
ils pensaient alors vois ce que je veux
dire quand je dis qu'il faut il faut
rire de tout si on avait ri comme ça
dans les rues de munich quand quand les
verts de des filets excusez moi je parle
pas des bonnes vertus fonctions que
cette petite opinion en lisant votre
livre j'ai appris qui se passe est drôle
de chose en france et particulièrement à
paris le vendredi soir après aperçoit
n'autorise pas le foot et vous avez lu
votre livre le fallait et il se passe
que vous entrez chez des gens qui en
sont à la fin d' apostrophes et qui
commence à se déshabiller tous ensemble
oui oui vous faisions une
comment s'appelle sa une par tous pour
nous rappeler à l'amour avec toi un
terme aux retards non parce que eh bien
tu vas pas encore imaginer une partouze
sur fond d'après ce pas que c'est plus
drôle que d'imaginer devant une émission
drôle d idée mais c'est pas grave c'est
ce que marc verly vous dites qu'ils
regardent l'apostrophent bâtiment
jusqu'au bout mais quand il voit jack de
freins commencent déjà à se déshabiller
donc ils ont regardé quand même toutes
les missions à ben oui oui madame la
dette est en forme c'est non
[Musique]